[birds chirping]
[Matt] You excited for biscuit week?
Of course I'm excited.
I mean, I'm a biscuit. I'm over the moon.
Mmm, yeah.
Hey, who's that fella over there?
He looks familiar.
-[Matt] Oh.
-[Noel] Off the telly.
Yeah, he's quite dishy in real life.
Lovely blue eyes.
Eh, what's he looking at us like that for?
-[Matt] Ooh.
-[Noel] All salivating.
He's getting a bit close, isn't he?
[Matt] Ooh, what's going on?
[screaming]
Oh, I suppose I'll have to introduce
the show on me own now.
Welcome to The Great Britishâ¦
[screaming]
[Noel] This time it's biscuit week.
Good luck, my little pretties.
[Noel] With a scorching signatureâ¦
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
â¦that's tight on time.
[Lizzie] They're not bubbling
and I'm panicking about it.
I'm never making brandy snaps again.
[Noel] A troublesome technicalâ¦
They're so soft I can't get it out.
It's like mashed potatoes.
-â¦that's hard to handle.
-Why?
[exclaims]
Oh, my God. What's wrong with you?
Don't panic.
[Noel] And a Showstopper
that sees the bakers
build childhood toys
out of delicate biscuit.
Oh, God, it's gonna fall.
[Noel] Causing tantrums in the tent.
[Amanda screams]
Oh, it collapsed.
What do they do with horses
that have broken legs?
Shoot 'em. [chuckles]
[opening theme music playing]
[indistinct chatter]
[Giuseppe] Week two, ready to go.
I'm feeling strangely confident today
which could be a good signâ¦
[chuckling] or the beginning of the end.
[Jairzeno] I'm not pleased
with how the first week went.
It was just bad time management.
Hopefully, today it'll be nice and smooth.
-It'll be polished.
-[Rochica] Good luck, guys.
Biscuit week.
It's exciting. It's also terrifying.
Biscuits are hard.
Sneaky little blighters.
[Amanda] I bake biscuits at home.
They normally take me three days,
so not gonna
get away with that here. [chuckles]
Good morning, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent for biscuit week.
Oh, my God, I love biscuits.
I once ate 119 biscuits.
-What, in one sitting?
-No, sporadically over 14 years.
[all laughing]
[Matt] For your signature challenge,
the judges would like you
to bake a batch of 24 brandy snaps.
The judges are looking
for perfectly baked lace biscuits.
Have to be identical,
have to have a good snap.
Your snaps can be any shape
but should be coated, dipped or filled.
You have two hours.
On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
Got me fast shoes on today,
so moving like the speed of light.
I'm feeling calm.
Just anything can happen, right?
Brandy snaps,
they're not the easiest thing to make.
[Maggie] Who can't make
a crispy identical lace biscuit?
Yes, easy peasy.
[Prue] I make brandy snaps quite often,
but they never last in my house
because they are just so delicious.
What I'd like to see
is 24 identical, perfect brandy snaps.
But lots of things can go wrong.
This is all about batch baking.
The key thing
is to get your brandy snap quite lacy.
You want those holes in there to create
that traditional brandy snap look.
It's all about textures for me.
It's about a crispy brandy snap
and a beautifully soft interior.
Whatever filling they choose,
there's going to be a danger
of the moisture in the filling
sogging up the biscuit.
It's not a brandy snap if it doesn't snap.
-[Paul] Hello, Lizzie.
-Hello.
So, Lizzie, brandy snaps.
Tell us about them.
So my brandy snaps are based on
my favourite fast food chain apple pie.
It's piping hot,
could burn your mouth, like, to the sun.
Has it been deep fried by any chance?
Yes, it has.
-Ermâ¦ [chuckles]
-We know what you mean.
And my dog likes a little, er, kids meal.
[Lizzie] Come on, Prue.
[Noel] Lizzie's terrier Prue
is no ordinary pooch.
A social media star,
she's even acquired a taste
for eating out.
[Lizzie] Oh, Prue.
[Noel] Lizzie's
fast food-inspired brandy snaps
will be filled with vanilla crème diplomat
and topped with apples
caramelised in calvados.
Yesterday,
were you in the tent practising these?
-Ermâ¦ [sighs]
-Oh.
-[Lizzie] I showed up to practise.
-Yeah.
And I put on
a famous film with a wizard in.
-Oh, let me guess. Harry Potter?
-Oh, yeah.
[Matt] So, you didn't do any baking?
No. Just watched Harry Potter.
-What a wonderful use of your time.
-[chuckles]
[Crystelle] Right, apples.
[Noel] But Lizzie's snaps
face stiff competition.
Battle of the apples.
[Crystelle] This is apple cider vinegar.
It's quite sharp but I just think
it just gives it a bit of that
kind of non-sweetness, which I want.
Erm, Prue said my mini rolls
were a bit sweet last week,
so I'm trying to take on her feedback
like a good student. [chuckles]
[Matt] With a degree
in French and Spanish,
-Crystelle's always been a high achiever.
-[Crystelle] Go. Whoo!
[Matt] On hand to keep her grounded,
are older sisters Chanelle and Corelle.
-[man] Who's the messiest?
-[woman] Oh, Crystelle.
Guys, I'm actually not the messiest.
[Matt] Her cross
between apple pie and crumble,
Crystelle's brandy snap
baskets will be loaded
with tart apple filling
and topped with a vanilla Chantilly cream.
What do you do when you're not baking?
You a wrestler?
-I do argue with my sisters.
-Turns into a wrestling match.
-Basically. Ermâ¦
-You ever attacked them?
No, but once
we were playing the trust game
where you have to fall back.
And I said, "Guys catch me"
and they just both walked past and I fell.
-Awful, I know.
-Off a building.
[chuckles] Fell off a building.
I'm a ghost.
-[Matt] While Crystelle and Lizzie
-[cork pops]
â¦reinvent the brandy snapâ¦
So satisfying, wasn't it?
Apple brandy, apple pie.
Makes sense, doesn't it? Logic.
Right.
â¦Maggie's keeping things classic.
[Maggie] I'm a very traditional baker.
So, my brandy snaps
are traditional brandy snaps.
I think sometimes things
get so over-sophisticated
that it's quite nice to see something
as it was meant to be a long time ago.
[laughs]
[Matt] Since retiring 12 years ago,
Maggie's travelled the world
seeking adventure in her trusty campervan.
Great. You're so much better now.
[Matt] But it's a taste of the English
summer that's inspired her bake.
She'll add crème de cassis
and blackcurrants to her cream filling
to help balance
the sweetness of her snaps.
[Maggie] This is my brandy snap.
It's just important the sugar melts
really evenly and that it doesn't boil.
It's a matter of being patient.
Do not rush it at the end.
[George] My sugar's not dissolving.
I've already had half an hour.
Come on, dissolve.
My flavours are gonna be
cinnamon brandy snap.
I'm gonna try and infuse
some of the cream with mastic.
Mastic is from a tree resin that grows
on the Greek island called Chios.
And Chios is where my mum's mum's from.
So my yaya's from there.
[Noel] George's yaya's love of baking
has been passed down
through the generations.
And many of his favourite recipes
come from mum, Spirula.
-[George] Perfect weather for a barbeque.
-Lovely.
[Noel] His brandy snaps
are a celebration of Cypriot flavours.
Chopped pistachios will decorate snaps
filled with orange blossom
and mastic cream.
How much mastika?
Be careful with the amount you put in.
It's quite a strong spice.
I can't have enough.
-It's about whether we can have enough.
-It's been fine in practice.
-Good luck, George. Thank you.
-Thank you.
It's just not dissolving.
I'm gonna turn this baby up.
[Noel] While George is feeling the heatâ¦
This might be a bad decision.
[Matt] Amanda's keeping her cool.
[Amanda] I've tried
a few different brandy snaps
and some of them you can cook on the hob,
melt the butter and the sugar together.
Erm, but this one is just throwing it
all together in one and not cooking it.
I have made them before.
They've come out really well.
Probably beginner's luck,
so I'm hoping today
I'll have beginner's luck again maybe.
[Matt] She might be new to brandy snaps,
but she's been baking since she was nine.
And it's a passion she's determined
to hand on to her teenage daughter Sophia.
I can't read your writin'.
-Writing.
-[enunciating] Writing.
[Matt] For extra flavour, Amanda will
add sesame seeds to her brandy snaps,
which she'll fill with zesty
orange curd and stem ginger cream.
-Paul Hollywood is a big fan of ginger.
-[Amanda] Is he?
-Yeah.
-Is he gonna say he hates ginger?
No.
-He might hate your ginger, but no.
-[chuckles]
He's ginger nuts.
[chuckling] Sorry, that's terrible.
-[Paul] Morning, Freya.
-[Freya] Hello.
-[Paul] All right, brandy snaps.
-I'm doing sort of like a cappuccino.
-Okay.
-[Freya] They've got a coffee liqueur in.
Then I've got
hazelnut praline layer on the top,
'cause I always get
a shot of hazelnut in my cappuccino.
And then I've got like froth on the top
which looks like
the top of the cappuccino.
Can you say cappuccino
one more time for me?
[laughs]
Good girl.
[Noel] A competitive
show jumper since she was 14,
Scarborough-born Freya
loves to hit the beach with horse Winnie.
You are beautiful.
[Noel] Inspired by her favourite drink,
Freya's brandy snap baskets
will combine hazelnut praline
with a coconut-based vegan coffee cream.
So, this is espresso powder.
I was worried that you were gonna think
the coffee was a bit strong,
'cause I like it really strong.
[Prue] I think
it sounds really interesting.
One more cappuccino for the road.
[chuckling] "Cappuccino."
[all laughing]
[Matt] Freya's not the only baker
giving their snaps a caffeine kick.
[Rochica] This is a coffee extract.
[Matt] But Rochica's come
with an extra shot of party vibes.
When I was a rep in Ibiza
I used to get a mocha with Irish cream.
[Matt] HR advisor Rochica
has swapped the beaches of Ibiza
for her sofa in Birmingham
where she now works from home.
Good morning, everyone.
[Matt] Shaped like mini ice-cream cones,
her coffee
and Irish cream-filled brandy snaps
will be decorated
with chocolate and crunchy hazelnuts.
[Rochica] The snap
and the flavour are the most important
and then uniformity
is a very close second.
I'm just weighing out my brandy snap balls
to make sure
they're exactly the same size.
Fifteen grams each.
[Matt] Another baker
keeping a close eye on consistencyâ¦
A heaped teaspoon is one.
â¦Chigs' snaps
come with a soupçon of sophistication.
[Chigs] Mine are espresso
martini brandy snaps.
I do enjoy one now and again.
[Matt] When 40-year-old Chigs
isn't hitting the local cocktail bars,
he enjoys a kick-about
with his nephews Mylan and Lukan.
[Chigs] Oh, no!
[Matt] Flavoured
with coffee liqueur and espresso,
Chigs' boozy coffee cream will fill ginger
and cinnamon-spiced brandy snaps.
So that's the first batch going in now.
The first batch is always touch-and-go,
hence why I made
extra batter just in case.
Yes.
[Noel] Producing perfect,
uniform batches of brandy snapsâ¦
-[Crystelle] Good luck.
-[Maggie] Have fun in there.
â¦will push our bakers to their limit.
I'm sure talking to them helps.
While I've got one batch in, I'll prepare
the next tray with another four.
-You've gotta spin plates in this one.
-[Lizzie] I'm going in.
[Noel] Oven time is critical.
Ten minutes I'm going with.
I'm going in for nine minutes.
I will check them after eight.
[Noel] Made almost entirely from sugar,
the snaps can turn
from underbaked and chewyâ¦
I see these are too blond.
â¦to burnt and bitter
in a matter of seconds.
They've got to be just right,
like the three bears and the porridge.
[Freya] I'm happy with how they look.
They go lacy from the heat,
'cause they bubble up
then the bubbles pop.
[Lizzie] They're not bubbling
and I'm panicking about it.
[Noel] Once out of the oven,
it's a race against the clock
to shape the snaps.
You've got to work really quickly
and they're really hot.
[gasps] Ow, ow, ow, ow.
[Noel] If that wasn't enough
to keep the bakers busyâ¦
[exclaims] I'm making chocolate ganache.
â¦there's the small matter
of their fillings.
I need to make sure I get everything
done properly and within time.
Oops.
Come on.
[Matt] After hitting
the trails with dog Maxie,
Jairzeno likes nothing more
than putting his feet up with a good book.
Having failed to finish
his Showstopper last week,
he's looking to bounce back
with ambitious brandy snaps
filled with dark chocolate
and lime ganache,
passion fruit curd and decorated
with chunks of spiced pineapple.
That is quite complicated.
-Anything else?
-[Prue] Any more layers?
-No.
-What about getting it done on time?
The plan is to get it done on time. Yes.
What I'm thinking about you
is you're quite a laid-back character.
-I am laid-back, so I'llâ¦
-[chuckles]
So my getting going might not be
the equivalent of other people.
Don't encourage him.
He wants to get on with it.
[laughs]
-Bakers, you have one hour lefâ¦
-â¦t.
[exclaims softly]
-I'm not sure that was divided up fairly.
-Oh, it was fine.
-That first hour went quick.
-I am running out of time.
I do need to get a wiggle on,
get my curd made.
[Noel] No matter what the bakers choose
to fill their brandy snaps withâ¦
[Chigs] So that's the cream,
coffee liqueur and espresso shot.
â¦care must be taken
to not only balance their flavoursâ¦
[Maggie] A bit of crème de cassis.
[Chigs] I need to taste the alcohol.
I'm just putting the syrup from
the stem ginger into the Chantilly cream.
â¦but textures too.
-[Amanda] And chopped-up ginger.
-[Jairzeno] This is ganache.
Put in more chocolate,
hopefully helps to thicken it up.
[Crystelle] This is my crumble.
It'll have the bite from the crumble,
and then the apples, I want them
to cook down to not like a mush.
Crystelle's got this lovely little
crumble texture going on.
Whereas mine's soft baby mush.
Like one congealed mess.
[Rochica] I'm making
a chocolate Irish cream filling.
I've just added the Irish cream.
There is plenty in here.
I'm measuring out
the spices for my chai crème pat.
Erm, I did a few experiments
to get chai flavour into crème pat.
I'm using insane amounts.
About 50 grams of cinnamon.
Almost two jars.
[Noel] Jürgen went
to university in Germany
and with a master's degree in physics,
makes good use of his scientific training
in his baking.
Last week's Star Baker,
Jürgen's chai spices,
cinnamon, cardamom and clove,
will flavour both his brandy snap baskets
and crème patisserie filling.
[Jürgen] This is my crème pat.
I've got starch.
Starch wraps around
protein strands of the egg yolk,
and, er, prevents it from curdling.
I'm a physicist by training.
The curious scientific mind is there.
Now I'm at the critical stage
where the crème pat is thickening.
I have just added hazelnut butter
to chocolate crème pat.
Hopefully, I got the ratio right.
These are gianduja snaps.
One of my favourite
ice cream flavours as a kid.
[Matt] From a family
of professional chefs,
it was growing up in Italy
that Giuseppe discovered his love of food.
[Giuseppe] Is it good?
[Matt] A passion his children Alberto,
Ricardo and Georgio also share.
Victory!
[Matt] Giuseppe will pipe
swirls of gianduja crème pâtissière
into brandy snap baskets
which he'll also flavour
with chopped roasted hazelnuts.
You've started your batches
of the brandy snaps already.
The crème pat is cooling down.
It's done. Now I'm starting offâ¦
-[Prue] First batch of snaps.
-[Giuseppe] Exactly.
Can you get it all out in time,
cool and ready?
It's a very odd way
of starting with your crème pat.
But I needed that to be the case
because if it doesn't
cool down sufficiently, it'll melt.
But you won't get the brandy snap
which is the key part.
[Giuseppe] Hopefully.
I don't think
we should stop you doing anything.
We should go away and let you get on.
-Thank you, guys.
-Thank you.
-Good luck.
You've worked your timings out,
don't listen to those two.
Sure.
Yeah, it's risky, admittedly,
but this is the Bake Off after all.
Uh, it needs to be ambitious,
otherwise there would be no point.
Bakers, you haveâ¦
[sing-song] half an hour.
[both] âª Half an hour, half an hour âª
[sighs]
First batch in,
now we play the waiting game.
These are my last four.
I'm happy with how they look.
-Finally we've got some cones going on.
-These have just stuck.
Come on, little brandy snaps,
you can do this.
I had loads of oil and they came off
perfect the first time.
[Jürgen] Last batch,
I'm very happy with them.
They have the lacy appearance
like stained-glass windows.
[Jairzeno] Hopefully,
I get a nice tart shape.
It's quite fiddly,
'cause you need to use your hands a lot.
-That's okay, just keep going.
-[Giuseppe] Next in.
[gasps]
Shush!
These look like Paul Hollywood's fingers.
[both laugh]
That's why he doesn't make brandy snaps,
'cause when he picks them up,
he can't tell what's what.
-[Maggie] Hang on, look at these hands.
-[Noel] You've got baker's hands.
-I've got builder's hands. Yes.
-Builder'sâ¦ [laughs]
I'm dipping the ends into the chocolate.
Now I'm gonna fill 'em.
[Rochica] I might need to do this again.
I am just making my filling again.
I think I over-whipped the last one.
I need to just chill.
And stop rushing. Stressing.
[Matt] Rochica's not the only one
starting from scratch.
It's like butter. I don't wanna
use the cream I've made
'cause it's a bit over-whipped.
Time's against me.
I was hoping to be piping
everything by now.
[Giuseppe] I've got
my last batch in the oven.
If I make it, it's gonna be by a second.
-[Chigs] George!
-I ain't got enough time, man.
You have. You've got this, bruv.
-Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
-Do we? [guffaws]
Brilliant.
[laughs] Gotta laugh, haven't you?
I'm never making brandy snaps again.
-This is looking a lot better.
-[Freya] This looks really nice.
The praline is exactly how I hoped.
Check this out, this gun here.
Is that purely from baking?
Well, what my colleague used to say,
I've got it not only here,
I've got it here as well.
[laughs boisterously]
[Maggie] Ooh, got the shakes.
This is just melted chocolate
and it's just to seal the bottom.
The moisture of the cream would melt
the sugar of the basket,
so the chocolate is there
mainly to prevent that.
With the added bonus
of an additional flavour.
I'm putting a layer of the ganache
into each tart case,
then I'll put a layer
of passion fruit curd.
Oh, no, this is disaster.
It's got a bit of ginger in there.
It's blocking the cream.
Oh, man, move it.
-Right, come on, come on, come on.
-How long do I have?
-Bakers, you have one minute left.
-[gasps]
-[George] Oh, get out of the way.
-Come on, George. You can do it.
Oh, sugar. This is terrible.
[Jürgen] Mango brings a freshness
balancing against the rich spices.
I weighed them all out
and they're still different sizes.
[Crystelle] I'm trying to do
the ugliest ones at the back.
I'm done.
[George] Oh, God,
this cream's going everywhere.
How many have I got now?
-[Giuseppe] There's one, two, threeâ¦
-[exhales]
Bakers, your time is up.
-Oh, done.
-Please step away from your bakes.
-[Chigs] Done it?
-Done it.
-[Freya] Do they look like a cappuccino?
-Yeah, lovely.
-I just hope it's tasty enough.
-Yeah.
-That's all it's all about.
[Noel] The bakers' brandy snaps
will now face
the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-[Prue] Hello, Freya.
-Hi.
I think they look absolutely scrumptious.
Oh, thank you.
[Paul] They do look quite dark.
Have you got coffee in the snaps?
Yeah, little bit of coffee liqueur.
-[Paul] Nice lace on it though.
-[Prue] A good snap on top.
Hmm, nice flavour.
Quite strong coffee,
maybe even a tiny bit too strong.
How many espressos did you put in there?
-Eight tablespoons.
-Sorry?
-Eight tablespoons?
-I like a lot of coffee.
You needed waking up.
You were steaming drunk last night.
It's not that bad. I love it.
For me, it's just
a little bit too much coffee,
but overall, I think
you've done a decent job.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
You made your brandy snaps
with the cold method?
[Amanda] I did.
[Paul] They're very thin
so therefore they're very delicate.
The whole shape of it is falling apart.
But the flavour is absolutely delicious.
Thank you.
[Paul] Stem ginger with the sesame seedâ¦
-Mmm.
-[Prue] It's really lovely.
I would like to just squinch that up,
'cause it doesn't look very good,
and have it for pudding.
-You would, wouldn't you?
-Oh, I would.
Thank you.
Told you he liked ginger, didn't I?
-You did.
-[Matt] Yeah.
[Paul] They're a little bit messy.
The laid-back thing, I'm beginning
to see this in some of your work.
[Jairzeno] There was a bit of rushing
in the last 15 minutes, soâ¦
-[Paul] We've had that before, haven't we?
-We have.
I didn't think the chocolate would go
with those fruit flavours, but it does.
I just think that
the flavours are too strong.
-Oh.
-I mean, I couldn't eat a whole one.
The idea was sound, but not well-executed.
Hmm.
-[Paul] Massive variety in size.
-I did weigh them out so I'm not sure.
[Prue] Some of them
are longer than the others.
[Paul] You've got the Irish cream, coffee,
chocolate and hazelnut.
-I think it's delicious.
-[Prue] And some booze.
Yeah, I added an extra tablespoon.
Thought you might like that.
You're right. You've got me in one.
Well done, Rochica.
-[Prue] Hello, George.
-Hello.
Bit irregular in size. Every one of them.
[crunching]
Mmm.
-That's mastika.
-[Paul] Orange blossom and mastika.
The flavours together work very well.
My issue is they just look a mess.
I'm a perfectionist,
and I really dislike serving that up.
-Wellâ¦
-Yeah.
You should take comfort in the fact
that they are original and sensational.
-[Paul] Thanks, George.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Sensational. Oh, God.
-[Matt] Yeah.
-There you go.
-I nearly fell over.
-[Matt] Well done.
-Cheers.
-[Prue] Hello, Crystelle.
-Hello.
I saw you saying a little prayer then.
Yeah, I was absolutely panicking. [laughs]
-Lovely snap.
-The flavour combination's beautiful.
That lovely crunch
from the crumble and the apples
with that little hint of cinnamon.
-You've done well with the flavours.
-[Prue] And the textures.
Thank you so much. Thanks.
[Paul] What's that on the top?
That's the fast food
clagginess that you get.
The congealed stuff.
Oh, delicious.
Well, I don't know
how to make it sound nice.
-Well, don't say "congealed."
-They're the words that come to me head.
-[Paul] There's very little lace in there.
-Yeah.
But it is delicious. That does
taste of apple. It tastes of brandy.
-[Paul] The crème diplomat's nice.
-Altogether it's a lovely mouthful.
-[Paul] Thank you very much.
-Ta.
[Prue] That's really pretty.
I think they look very elegant,
pretty uniform in colour,
nice lace as well in the brandy snap.
Let's see what it tastes like.
The brandy snap is delicious,
crisp, nicely flavoured.
[Paul] Chocolate doesn't
come through massively strong.
So what's happened is
it's sort of lost its way.
You do get this blast of hazelnut,
but otherwise, you've done very well.
-Cheers, guys.
-[Prue] Well done.
[Prue] They're nice and lacy.
[Paul] The chocolate comes through,
the brandy snap's got a lovely snap.
Just the right amount of sweetness
in there as well.
The cream's okay, but you've lost
a little bit of the coffee flavour.
-It's just a little bit weak.
-Fair enough.
-Very good.
-Thank you very much.
[Prue] They're very small
and they could have had
a more colour on them.
I'm really quite disappointed.
[Prue] Because you've done a traditionalâ¦
-[Maggie] Yes.
-â¦filled brandy snap.
-The cream has sogged up the brandy snap.
-Yes.
Which weren't quite baked enough anyway
so they're really chewy.
-Right.
-But they are delicious.
[Paul] I love the tanginess
from the blackcurrant,
but, um, the practicalities really
haven't worked out very well.
No indeed,
and that's what's disappointing.
-Onwards and upwards.
-[laughs]
Thank you very much.
[Paul] Overall, they look pretty good.
[Prue] Nice and even.
They are lovely and thin.
-[crunches]
-[Matt] I hear a crunch.
-[Prue] Mmm-hmm.
-I can.
The blend of the spices,
the cardamom and the cinnamon
work beautifully well.
It's so easy to get it wrong
by putting too much in,
it overwhelms either the brandy snap
or the cream.
But it just doesn't. I think
texture-wise, you've done well as well.
The crème pat's perfect.
It's not too stodgy.
-I think you've done well on that. Yeah.
-[Prue] Mmm.
[Paul] Thank you, Jürgen.
-I'm just gonna try a bit myself.
-[Jürgen] Yes.
-It means nothing from me.
-It means a lot for me.
-Oh, you can come back. Thank you.
-Welcome.
[Jürgen] Couldn't have gone better.
It was definitely worth
developing the spice chai crème pat.
Which took a lot of time, was amazing.
Flavour's good. They liked the clagginess,
which is what I was after.
Maybe I shouldâ¦ I need a vocabulary.
So I canâ¦ Is it, not a vocabularâ¦
What's a dictionâ¦ Like the dictionâ¦
Thesaurus, I need a thesaurus.
We won't just expand on baking,
we'll expand my mind.
[Giuseppe] The comments were very positive
and, uh, very constructive.
This is a good step
in the right direction.
Prue used the word "sensational."
In my head all I've got is,
uh, "they didn't look right."
But she really liked it.
[Jairzeno] The finish was rushed
because I was rushing at the end,
so if I was judging, I would agree
with them about the messiness.
Well, it was a bit of a disaster, really.
In the technical this afternoon.
I can only go up from here,
there is no going down.
[Matt] Biscuit week isn't about to get
any easier for our 11 bakers
who now face a mystery
shrouded in gingham.
Bakers, it's time
for your technical challenge
which today has been set by Paul.
-Paul, any words of advice?
-[all chuckle]
This is pretty straightforward,
but read your recipe.
We want perfection.
[Matt] As ever, this task is judged blind,
so we will ask Paul and Prue
to leave the tent.
[Noel] Bye-bye.
What I don't understand
is Paul's standing there,
scowling at everyone.
-Why doesn't he just tell 'em what to do?
-He's got a lot on his mind.
Like what?
He's deciding whether to watch
Fast & Furious 6 or The Expendables 3.
[all laugh]
Bakers, for your technical challenge,
Paul would like you
to make that childhood favourite,
the sandwiched jammy biscuit.
Made up of two perfectly-baked
short and tender biscuits,
perfectly set jam and smooth buttercream.
We would like you to make 12 biscuits.
You have one hour and 45 minutes.
-[Noel] On your marksâ¦
-Get setâ¦
[Noel] Bake.
[Chigs] I've had jam biscuits,
the sandwich ones.
I think I know what I'm doing.
Just need to make sure they're perfect.
[Rochica] I've never made jammy biscuits,
but I have eaten them.
I kind of know what I'm looking for.
[Amanda] Who makes biscuits
you can buy in the shop?
You can get a tub for 11p, can't you?
Paul, jammy biscuits, why?
I think jammy biscuits should
be a very familiar biscuit to the bakers
and I thought it'd be a great challenge.
The recipe is pretty straightforward,
but you gotta get
all the elements spot-on.
We've given the bakers stamps to get
that definition in those lines and swirls.
And how you get the definition
is chilling the biscuit dough down.
If it's soft when you press it,
you're going to lose that ridge.
And obviously we're looking
for the same thickness.
You don't want a thin top and a fat base.
And what about texture?
Is it a shortbread?
It is. When you bite in,
you have that gorgeous biscuit
that snaps in the mouth
and that buttery flavour inside.
See, the jam cuts the sweetness a bit.
That's really lovely.
I thought this was a simple biscuit.
It's deceptively difficult.
It's quite a warm day.
It's all to do
with the temperature of the dough.
-They've gotta use the fridge.
-It's not that hot.
Well, for you. You're South African.
Paul said,
"Read the recipe very carefully."
So I'm trying to ponder
on every single word.
I think he's taking the mickey when
he said read your instructions. That's it.
They want you to be in the know-know,
but you don't know.
The first thing to do is make
a smooth raspberry jam.
Put the jam, sugar in there,
and all the raspberries.
I'm not a jam maker. I'm a jam eater.
I don't even eat that much jam, either.
I'll leave that to heat up
and get all mushy.
So I'm now just on to me biscuits
while me jam heats up.
Next thing says, "Make the biscuit dough."
Easy peasy.
Given the order
the ingredients are listed,
I think the creaming method
will work best for this one.
[Freya] Ooh, bit fast.
And the creaming
of the butter incorporates air.
Soon as that's light and fluffy
I'm gonna add the egg vanilla extract
and then I'm gonna sift the cornflour
and the flour together
and then I'll put that in last.
What does a tender biscuit mean?
I've heard of a short biscuit.
But a tender biscuit?
Yeah, I don't know what he's on about.
-Sensitive biscuit. Sensitive, tenderâ¦
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Emotional.
-Bit like me.
I'm just concerned.
This batter's literally wet.
I want it to be a lot firmer.
Because it's hot in here
the butter's really soft.
I'm gonna chill it down for a bit.
You've got to rest it for a while
before it gets workable
to get the butter solid again.
It's in there.
Jam is almost at jam temperature.
I'm just gonna let that bubble.
The setting point is about
105 degrees Celsius.
So I reached that
and I did a setting test.
If you put a drop of jam
onto the bowl, you nudge the drop,
you get this kind of skin ripple,
that should be perfect.
[Rochica] Oh, no. I just burnt it.
I wasn't paying attention.
I can't use that.
I'm just gonna start again.
And hopefully I won't burn this one.
They want a smooth
raspberry jam, so no bits.
[Jürgen] The jam should set,
fingers crossed.
[Crystelle] That is the amount
of jam I have. What?
I cooked it to the jam temperature.
I think. Not very much, is it?
[Matt] Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Freya] It says roll out the doughâ¦
[Lizzie] Using the "flutteredâ¦"
I think that's how you pronounce it.
"Use the fluted cutter
to create 24 rounds."
Fluted. Oh, okay. Fluted cutter.
[George] Is that fluted?
That must be fluted,
'cause that's just round.
[Lizzie] Learn a new word every day.
I think I can just about
get 12 biscuits on one sheet.
[Crystelle] It's such a soft dough.
I have no idea
how I'm gonna cut out circles of this.
[Freya] It's so hot in here.
The butter's just completely melting.
I'm just gonna throw them
back in the freezer again.
I'm chilling the dough
to get it stiff enough to work with.
[Amanda] I'd like the dough to be harder.
It's still quite soft.
Just need to keep an eye on that jam
because I don't want to burn it again.
Gonna start rolling the dough out.
Okay, "Make the buttercream."
Lots of detail, as always.
He's emphasised in the recipe, "smooth."
He's in smooth mode.
[Jürgen] The longer you beat it,
the smoother it will become.
I'm gonna beat this
until the cows come home.
[Rochica gasps] Fluted. Oh, no.
I've cut them round and not fluted.
-Bakers, you have--
-Whoa, what are you doing?
I'm gonna tell 'em
how long they've got left.
No, don't do that.
No spoilers, I'm watching the show.
-[Noel] I've gotta tell--
-[Matt] No, don'tâ¦
Okay, cover your ears.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Yeah. No spoilers, please.
Okay. I've got to go back to the biscuits.
-[Amanda] It's quite cold.
-[Giuseppe] Set enough.
[Jürgen] "Using the biscuit stamp,
emboss the biscuits."
-Ah, yes.
-[Lizzie] It is quite cool, isn't it?
The biscuit dough was sticking
to the stamp, so I've floured it.
Why?
With a heart-shaped cutter,
stamp a single heart shape
out of the centre
of 12 of your stamped rounds.
They're so soft I can't get it out.
It's like mashed potato.
[Noel] Turning out biscuits with
perfectly-defined hearts and swirlsâ¦
[George] What is this? What is this?
...will be nigh on impossible.
[Crystelle] It's very soft, but I should
get them in the oven.
[Noel] Unless their dough is chilled
to a firm texture before it's baked.
[Giuseppe]
There is so much butter in there.
If you put it straight in the oven
the whole dough will collapse.
I'll stick these in the freezer.
[Giuseppe] This is the trickiest part.
If I rush this, I will ruin it.
Although if I look around the room
I can see people
sticking stuff in the oven
and that's getting me anxious.
[George] I'm going in the oven.
[Maggie] I would like to have them
in the freezer before I cook them.
But I don't want to run out of time.
And I'm going to bake them
for six minutes.
I feel like these biscuits
can't catch any colour.
They're very pale, aren't they?
Anaemic biscuits?
I just have to wait. This is killing me.
[Freya] I'm doing the same as you--
Let's not open it,
let's wait for two minutes.
[Noel] You've written
your own notes on Paul's recipe?
-Are you just writing bottom?
-[Maggie] Went in at bottom at three.
Paul Hollywood's bottom.
I've seen it. It's like two beige moons.
Dancing in the sky.
Take this man away.
I'm far too old to cope with that.
-Although the thought is rather nice.
-[both laughing]
This biscuit dough is so soft. Oh, no.
I might have to try stamping them
afterwards and see what happens.
I need to cut a heart out.
This challenge is so deceitful.
It's nice and cold in that freezer.
[Jürgen] I'll put them in the oven.
It should keep definition.
I'm gonna have a go.
[Jürgen] It's 150 degrees
so it's not too hot.
I'll check in five minutes.
[timer beeping]
-You having a daydream then?
-No, I'm just waiting for the biscuits.
[Noel] I thought you were thinking,
"if I pull this tent down
and push Giuseppe over,
I'll go down in history
as the most disruptive baker."
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
[Lizzie] Oh, no.
I'm going in for eight minutes.
And I've bumped it up to 160.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
-[Lizzie] This is awful, George.
-It's a horrible challenge.
-Matt, come here.
-[Matt] Yeah?
-Look how tidy this is.
-[Matt] Wow.
And look, shambles.
-It's a mess.
-[Crystelle] What are you saying about me?
That your whole work area
is an absolute shambles.
-It's devastating. Look at this bench.
-She's not allowed to look.
-Yeah, you're not allowed to look.
-[Jürgen] She's not allowed to look.
[Lizzie] Coming out,
they haven't really got a swirl.
They are coming out now
whether they like it or not.
I think they're done. [exclaims]
Oh, my God. What's wrong with you?
Don't panic.
-[Crystelle] I'm not panicking.
-[Noel] You only lost one.
[Crystelle] And I've got a few spares.
Yeah. They look all right.
They're a bit pale,
but if I wait any longer,
I probably won't be able to finish them.
[Chigs] I'm gonna have to
sacrifice the swirl.
[Maggie] They've just got to be cold.
If they're hot, the buttercream
is just gonna go bleurgh.
[Rochica] They're not baking that well.
-[Jürgen] Happy.
-[Giuseppe] That'll do.
[Amanda] They won't take long to cool,
they're really thin.
[Rochica] Hmm. Gonna cut it fine.
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Yeah, I'm gonna go back in.
I'd rather have a baked biscuit.
"To serve, sandwich the biscuits
with a layer of buttercream
and a layer of jam."
Putting the buttercream on atom by atom.
Look at the colour of this jam.
It's beautiful.
[Crystelle] Man, I can't believe
this happened to my jam.
I've never handled jam like this
in my life.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Dust with icing sugar,
leaving the heart visible.
-[Freya] I just need to dust.
-Come on, come on, come on.
[Jürgen] Yeah, good, I think.
These are so dodgy.
And I'm never, ever making these again.
[Rochica] Ah! Terrible.
Size is a bit different, but they're here.
[Rochica] Yeah,
they're still a bit doughy.
Bakers, your time is up.
Step away from your bakes.
-Cheers.
-[Crystelle] Cheers.
Oh. Jürgen's tucking in.
-[Noel] Good?
-They're awful, but they're done.
Please bring your biscuits
down to the gingham table.
-That be a lot of biscuits.
-[Noel] A lot of biscos.
[Matt] Paul and Prue are expecting
12 uniform short jammy biscuits
with clearly-defined swirls and hearts,
deliciously tart raspberry jam
and ultra-smooth buttercream.
And they have no idea whose is whose.
Right, shall we start over here?
-[Prue] They've lost a lot of definition.
-[Paul] And they're different sizes.
The top ones aren't so well baked
which is why the bottom ones are smaller.
The texture's there, it's crumbly.
And you have the set jam and buttercream.
It's just an issue with the look.
Okay, moving on to number two,
it's lost some of its shape.
Quite flat, aren't they? See the
difference with the top and the bottom?
-[Prue] That's been rolled too thinly.
-[Paul] Mmm-hmm. It's about consistency.
It's a little hard. It's not buttery.
-[Paul] But when you look at theseâ¦
-[Prue] Colour and definition are good.
[Paul] There's a couple where the top
is much smaller than the bottom.
-It's nice and delicate, crumbly.
-[Prue] Mmm.
-It's got a good flavour.
-It's a proper shortbread.
[Paul] Moving on, you want the icing sugar
to highlight stuff, not hide stuff.
We will find it.
[all chuckling]
-Thick at the bottom, thin at the top.
-They are slightly underbaked.
[Paul] Okay, moving on.
-[Prue] Very small.
-[Paul] Yeah, they are.
But they're pretty consistent
all the way down, yeah.
But there's no definition in there at all.
-Or underneath.
-[Prue] No.
Mmm.
But the biscuit is lovely.
As it should be.
[Paul] Yeah. Now these look good.
The hearts are quite defined.
There's a bit of definition
on there from the lines.
[Prue] Yeah.
Hmm.
-[Paul] It's got a good consistency.
-[Prue] They're very nice.
[Paul] There's a bit of definition
but there's inconsistencies.
It's quite thick, that buttercream.
I like the biscuit.
But it's a bit too much jam.
[Paul] It's too sweet.
Erm, moving on,
a lot of icing sugar again.
[Prue] This is very dark jam.
I reckon I could paste
a poster on the wall with that.
It's been over-boiled.
The jam ruins that
'cause it alters all the textures.
This has lost a lot of its shape.
[Prue] Those are very uneven.
[Paul] You've got to
cut and chill the biscuit.
That's how you get the definition
and stop it from shrinking in the oven.
The jam looks great,
but that buttercream, it's justâ¦
-[Prue] Hardly any.
-â¦a thin smear. Slightly underdone.
Talking of underdone.
[Prue] That's got
no stamp on it at all, has it?
-This is raw actually.
-Probably hasn't even hit the fridge.
Hasn't hit the oven either.
At least not for long enough.
[Paul] There's a bit of definition here.
-They're a bit thin.
-[Prue] I quite like them thin.
Cream's good, shape's good.
-I think the jam flavour is good.
-[Paul] Jam's good.
[Matt] Paul and Prue will now rank
the jammy biscuits from worst to best.
In 11th spot is this one.
-Rochica, did it actually go in the oven?
-It did.
It needed longer, there's no definition.
In tenth place, we have this one.
Jam ruined it, I'm afraid.
In ninth spot we have this one.
Very little definition, very, very thin.
[Matt] George is eighth, Chigs seventh,
Lizzie sixth, Maggie fifth
and Amanda is fourth.
In third spot we have this one.
-Whose is this?
-That's me.
Freya, these weren't too bad.
You've lost a little bit of definition
but you were nearly there.
Little bit longer in the oven.
In second place, this one.
Giuseppe, I thought
these were absolutely lovely.
But you could've put
a bit more filling in them.
So in first spot we have this one.
-[cheering]
-Crazy.
You did have the definition
and the biscuit tasted lovely.
Thank you.
[Jürgen] It's almost unreal.
It's an unbelievable day
and I'm truly exhausted now.
Jürgen has been renamed
"The Baking Terminator."
Nothing stops him.
He doesn't have the Austrian accent,
but he's German,
so it's close enough. [laughs]
[Rochica] Definitely the hardest moment
in the tent for me. I'm still optimistic.
It all rests on tomorrow.
[Jairzeno] It could've gone better today.
Even though you plan so much,
the time just seems toâ¦ yeah.
A bad morning and I needed a little higher
to bring me out of the depths.
I feel I'm under
a lot of pressure tomorrow.
[Noel] There's just the Showstopper
challenge left before Prue and Paul decide
who'll be leaving the tent
and who's destined for Star Baker.
Hello and welcome to the Matt Lucas Show
with my special guests,
the Beverley Sisters.
[Noel chuckles]
[Matt] For your Showstopper challenge,
Prue and Paul want you to make
a 3D biscuit replica
of your favourite childhood toy.
[Noel] Your biscuit toy
needs to be delicious,
but also there needs
to be an interactive element.
[Matt] It could be wheels
that turn on a car,
or lighting in a doll's house
or Internet in case they wanna get
some work emails out of the way
before the weekend or hop on a Zoom.
[Noel] I had a Zoom
with a doll the other week.
It was Chucky the killer doll.
Nice guy, actually, off camera.
[Matt] I actually facetimed Action Man
the other day.
Great body but, uh, took his trousers offâ¦
[whispering] nothing there.
-[Noel] You have four hours.
-[normally] On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
[Rochica] I really need to do well today.
Just wanna keep a cool head.
[Maggie] I'm feeling
absolutely fine this morning.
There's only one place to go
today and that's up.
[Lizzie] This bake brings back
loads of kid memories.
Yeah, just fills me with joy
just looking at it.
[Prue] This week's Showstopper
is a childhood toy
and we want them to be interactive.
Children's toys are not much fun
if they don't do something,
but it's quite difficult
to do out of biscuit.
The bakers have to be
engineers as well as bakers,
because they need to think
about how they're gonna bring
this three-dimensional
biscuit scene together.
I think they're gonna use
something like a gingerbread,
because it's robust, it's strong.
If it's too soft it could just collapse.
-[Paul] Hi, George.
-Hi.
Tell us all about your toy biscuit design.
So I'm doing an aeroplane.
My aeroplane used to stick on my ceiling
and it had a propeller that turned.
You'd throw it and it'd go round the room.
I was fascinated by it.
[Matt] Whizzing high
above Greek biscuit clouds,
George's gingerbread aeroplane
will be crafted from ten separate pieces
and has a special feature.
It's got a motor
that takes the plane round.
-You've got a motor?
-Yes.
Wow.
Have you got enough time?
'Cause it sounds
like you'd need about two years.
I know. I've got an awful lot to do.
-Keep working.
-I will.
-Good luck, mate.
-Yeah. Thanks.
[Noel] While George plays planes,
Lizzie's off on the road.
[Lizzie] I am making a chocolate
and ginger toy truck.
I should know how to build cars.
I do work in a car factory.
[Noel] Her chocolate gingerbread truck
will feature moving wheels
and for extra interactive fun, she'll add
a paint palette so it can be coloured in.
[Noel] Making a little Brum-Brum car.
Paul's favourite.
Your favourite, too.
There's an art palette.
I don't have anything to do
with the judging, you know that, right?
-You're bribing the wrong cat.
-That's fine. [laughs]
[Matt] Jairzeno's hoping to bribe
the judges with a toy vehicle of his own.
[Jairzeno] I'm making a sailing ship,
I've always been interested
in all those ships and all those sails.
[Matt] After capsizing in his signature,
today he needs to stay afloat.
But the ship has a heavy load,
biscuit treasure, battery-powered lights,
two masts and colossal rice paper sails.
[Jairzeno] The sails are kind of big
so if my sailing ship could just stand up,
you know, I'll be happy.
[Noel] Maggie's also off to sea.
[Maggie] As a post-war child,
there weren't many toys around.
But we always went to the beach,
'cause it was a cheap day out.
We had access to people with beach huts.
So skim boards, bodyboards,
that kind of thing were part of our life.
[Noel] With childhood toys
in short supply,
she's making the beach her toy,
featuring a gingerbread surfer
who can be pulled through the waves.
I mean my first thought
was this is not a toy.
-[Maggie] No.
-[Prue] But you can play with models.
[Maggie] With all honesty,
I can't remember a favourite toy.
-Bucket and spade, that was a toy.
-Bucket and spade.
[Matt] Toys were also a luxury
in Jürgen's childhood days.
[Jürgen] My brother and myself
didn't have many toys
because we grew up very poor.
And so my grandpa made some windmills.
So we had a mini Dutch windmill
on a pole in the garden.
[Matt] Jürgen's gingerbread windmill
is the tallest toy in the tent.
Engineered with a hidden wooden axle,
the top turns
and tuile biscuit sails spin.
So that's the interactive bit.
-It actually moves.
-Clever.
-[Jürgen] I hope to have no breakages.
-[Paul] Good luck, Jürgen.
-Thank you very much.
-You don't need luck.
[Noel] To help keep lady luck on side,
most of the bakers are working
with sturdy gingerbread.
Very few biscuits are strong enough
to support a 3D structure,
other than ginger biscuits or gingerbread.
[Noel] But just how stable
their 3D toys are
depends on how thin they roll.
[Rochica] I've done it as thin as I could.
I don't want the biscuits to be too thin,
'cause then they won't hold up.
-[Noel] And the bake.
-Good luck, my little pretties.
Toy truck. Fifteen minutes.
[Noel] Perfectly baked gingerbread
should be crisp on the outside
with a tender centre.
And while delicious to eat,
could be too weak to build with.
It's all a balancing act,
because if you bake them nice and soft
it might fall under its own weight.
[Noel] A risk Freya isn't willing to take.
I want them like quite dark.
Overly done, you know?
[Noel] Named after
her beloved horse Winnie,
she aims to stay in the saddle
with a vegan rocking horse
and Freya's hoping
her well-baked gingerbread
will give her the edge
during construction.
I think it is quite a test
of people's ability
to structurally build things.
We are hoping for the best with Winnie.
[Matt] But Winnie isn't the only horse
Prue and Paul will get to play with.
[Amanda] I am doing a rocking horse.
I'm not the only one doing
a rocking horse, no.
[giggles]
The lovely Freya's doing
a rocking horse as well.
They're different.
Mine's American sugar cookie.
[Matt] Amanda's the only baker
to reject sturdy gingerbread,
risking a soft-baked sugar cookie instead.
Flavoured with lemon and cardamom,
she'll assemble pieces
of her delicate biscuit
to create a working rocking horse.
I think it's very ambitious.
I was gonna go for
the gingerbread as an easier option,
but I can't stand a hard biscuit.
I like the bite in it a bit more buttery.
-Have you practised this?
-I have, yeah.
Okay. Well, good luck.
I'm coming out.
I'm starting to think
that I've over-baked it.
But it's better very hard.
At least it's not gonna fall down.
[Matt] While the gingerbread bakers
have made their biscuits
as hard as they dareâ¦
Are these supposed to be
quite as brown as they are?
-Yes. They have a suntan.
-Ah, they do.
â¦Amanda's soft-baked
sugar cookie rocker has already cooled.
[Amanda] Just gonna go for it.
[Matt] And she's ready
to start constructing.
[Amanda] I've got horrible visions
of this thing just cracking open.
I just can't risk the biscuit breaking,
'cause it's holding the whole body up.
[yelling]
Oh, it collapsed.
Quick. Repair, repair, repair.
God.
It's not good.
Bakers, you are halfway "througe".
-It's pronounced "through."
-Is it?
Also you've been saying
her name wrong. It's Pruge, not Prue.
-Oh.
-[Amanda] God.
I've just glued it back together again
with some sugar. I'm panicking.
[Noel] How are you?
-I'm okay, thank you.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Really?
You've done something wrong, haven't you?
There was a tiny little breakage.
My horse is not rocking.
[Noel] Bet you were naughty at school.
-I was a bit naughty at school, yeah.
-How can I tell?
-[Amanda] But I didn't smash stuff.
-[Noel] No.
[Amanda] Oh, I did break a window.
Well, look, don't break any windows,
tear any flaps.
-[chuckles] Okay. I know what you mean.
-Tent. You know.
Tent flaps. I got it, it's fine.
This has gone somewhere.
I can't even pull this out of the gutter.
[chuckling]
[Noel] While Amanda worries
about her rocking horseâ¦
[Amanda] If I move it,
it'll probably break,
but don't forget,
this rocking horse is really old.
â¦the rest of the bakers
press on with decoration.
That bikini looks like
Elton John's glasses.
[Maggie laughs]
I don't want them to say, "That's a mess."
It's Paul and Prue airlines, man.
[Chigs] I'm just trying to get my balls
prepped now, ready to go.
Mine is gonna be a snooker table.
Playing snooker
was a big part of my childhood.
Brings back fond memories.
[Matt] Chigs' spiced gingerbread
snooker table will be fully functional
with balls made from fondant icing
and biscuit cues.
-[Matt] Are you a good snooker player?
-I used to be okay.
-[Matt] Really?
-Yes.
âª Snooker loopy nuts are we
Me and him and them and me âª
âª We'll show you what you can do
With a load of balls and a snooker cue âª
Yay, get in there.
[Noel] Games are proving
a popular toy in the tent.
So I'm making a game called reversi.
I found out recently
that it's actually a very old game.
It dates back from the 19th century.
[Noel] Giuseppe will harness
his skills as an aircraft engineer
to build his ancient game complete
with curved counter grooves
and 30 chocolate orange sable counters.
There are some engineering aspects
into doing this,
especially for the assembly.
[Matt] Rochica also fancies a game.
[Rochica] I'm making
a pinball Showstopper.
[Matt] And hers has even more complex
parts to engineer.
You'll be able to use the flickers
as well, to flick the ball.
The ball rolls down the ramp, so yeah.
[Matt] Having come last
in the technical challenge,
she hopes her dynamic
pinball game will be a winner.
It features a lemon shortbread ramp,
multiple wheels and marshmallow balls.
[Rochica] So this will be
the marshmallow pinball.
Oh, my gosh, what a mess. I'm stressed.
Oh. [chuckling] Stuck myself together.
[Noel] Crystelle also needs to better
her poor technical performance
and she's going all out
with her toy today.
[Crystelle] This is a little vanity unit.
So I am making
poppy seed biscuit lipsticks,
my makeup brushes and a sugar mirror.
I'm quite tight on time today. Come on.
Right, I'm movingâ¦ [gasps]
My mumâ¦ Right, we're fine.
[Noel] Made from over 50 parts,
her vanity playset features
lemon and poppyseed lipsticks and a
gingerbread drawer with jewellery inside.
Sweet lights surround the mirror.
-[Noel] I fell through a mirror once.
-[Crystelle] Through it?
And ended up in this tent and I haven't
managed to get out since I've been here.
-Oh.
-And later on--
-You're gonna jump in there.
-I'm gonna jump through that.
-God, it sounds like a film.
-It does sound like a film.
-Or an A-ha video.
-[Crystelle laughs]
Bakers, you have one hour left.
You know it's pronounced "our," right?
-What school did you go to?
-I didn't go to school. I'm a feral child.
I was raised by pangolins.
[Amanda] Okay, I wanna
get the body on the slats.
[exhales] I need to build myself up to it.
Construction, that's the hardest bit,
fitting pieces of gingerbread together.
[Rochica] I'm using isomalt,
which is sugar,
to keep everything in place.
I need to make sure I'm careful,
and I've got on my gloves as well.
Hopefully, the whole thing
doesn't collapse under its weight.
-I can't even breathe now.
-Please don't let this fall.
[whimpers]
If that could just stay up.
Yeah, I'm rolling.
If you finish today, Paul's gonna do
a small dance in your honour.
In a skimpy dress.
[George] No pressure. Come on.
How long have we got?
[Matt] Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Guys, I'm freaking out.
[Freya] So stressful doing this in a rush.
[Lizzie] I'm assembling a car
with great difficulty.
I hope the windmill spins.
They're quite important.
[Amanda] Okay, I have to do it.
Oh, God, it's gonna fall.
This is the bit where
it all goes wrong, isn't it?
The snooker table. It's behaving
at the moment. [laughs nervously]
There's several in it, so that's good.
[Crystelle] Come on.
Hold the top, just don't let them
slip out your hands, please.
Okay.
Just wanna keep a cool head, keep going.
-[Giuseppe] It's very tense, definitely.
-[George] Come on, man.
Please don't fall.
Oh, my God, what did you just do?
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
It's gonna go.
Something's going.
[yelling]
Breakage.
Don't know what I'm doing.
Quick, repair.
[George] Shall we see if it goes 'round?
Oh, dear.
Yeah, I mean,
there's an element of movement.
No, it should be moving.
If it collapses it collapses. [sighs]
[Amanda] Mine's proper broken already.
Ooh.
The beach huts are a little bit messy.
But I've got the shakes.
[George] Motor broke.
Oh, for God's sake.
Can't work out what's wrong.
You know what's wrong? British technology.
[laughs]
Typical.
It broke.
[Amanda] Oh, no, my legs are falling off.
Can I help?
[Amanda] I might try
and stick some more glue on it.
-[Freya] Right, well, I've got it.
-Thank you, darling.
What do they do with horses
that have broken legs?
-Shoot 'em.
-[chuckling] I know.
[Crystelle] Hearts.
[Chigs] Snooker balls.
-[Giuseppe] Counters.
-[George] Yes.
[exclaiming]
I can stick that through the ship.
[Amanda] Thank you, darling.
[Freya] Right.
[Maggie] It's not very neat.
[Jairzeno] Scary putting this together.
Nearly there, nearly there.
[George] Candyfloss. Form the clouds.
[Chigs] Making it look as good as I can.
[motor whirring noisily]
[Amanda] Just gonna go for it. [yelling]
Oh, no. Oh, no.
-Disaster strikes.
-[both chuckle]
[Amanda] It's gone.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your biscuity bakes.
[Jairzeno] Oh, no. It's more like
a shipwreck than a ship.
[Maggie] It's just messy.
-[Chigs] Come on, don't cry.
-I know.
[Amanda yelling]
Mine's just completely collapsed.
-[Freya] No, no, no.
-[Amanda] The head's come off.
[Chigs] Oh, babe.
Disaster.
That was so pretty though, Amanda.
Yeah. Compared to my ship.
What do you want, some buttercream?
I need some comfort.
Thank you.
[Matt] It's judgement time
for the bakers' interactive toys.
George, would you like to fly on down?
-[motor whirring]
-[all cheering]
That is really wonderful.
That is definitely interactive.
-That's amazing.
-Even sounds like a plane.
It's a pretty basic plane,
but it does go round.
The design on this is great.
[Noel groans]
-That can be repaired.
-[laughs]
Nice wing.
It's not too hard. But it's very crisp.
-Shall we taste both?
-[Paul] They work well as a sort of cloud.
[Prue] What are the flavours in there?
-Pistachios, brandy.
-What's not to like?
-Well done, George. Thank you.
-Thanks.
That's so good. So good.
[Paul] Ingenious.
You have a lot of moving parts.
You can play with it. Look.
-[exclaims]
-Oh, no. [laughs]
You've broken it on the first go.
[Prue] I did. But we can do it like that.
[Paul] Yes.
It's so delicate, it's so thin.
-The texture's spot-on.
-[Prue] Very good.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you, Rochica.
Properly engineered.
The way that the counters sit in
the little recess here. It looks amazing.
It's a very classic ginger biscuit.
I quite like that.
It's the cardamom
and the cloves coming through.
-[Prue] Well done, Giuseppe.
-Thank you.
-[all cheering]
-[Paul] Oh, nearly!
That's very clever.
-[Prue] Now it just has to taste wonderful
-I know.
[Prue] And it's a little bit cakey.
But I like that, especially if it's thick,
you don't want it to be too hard.
[Paul] It's perfect.
-But you're missing a row of red balls.
-[Chigs] I know.
-Trust you to count them.
-[all laugh]
There's a show, "Paint Along with Prue."
[Paul] Getting out of jail free
by adding that palette
and saying "paint it yourself"
is interesting.
The ginger and the chocolate together,
it is probably too strong.
-Okay.
-[Prue] You know what?
If you have it with a bit of icing,
it tones it down and it's delicious.
-Well done.
-Ta.
[Matt] Well done.
With that painting skills, you could get
a job in our factory if this goes wrong.
Done.
[Prue] Look at that.
[Prue chuckles]
You've created quite a high structure,
but having said that, it is so thin.
[Prue] Well I agree, it's sehr gut.
-It really is.
-Danke schön.
It looks beautiful.
[Paul grunts]
It's not overly sweet at all.
But it's got
a lovely flavour in the mouth.
-[Prue] Very nice.
-[Paul] You've done a great job.
Again. Konditor meister.
-Thank you.
-[Matt] Well done.
Oh, God. Gonna be sick. I can't do this.
[Noel] Paul would look good with them on.
[all laughing]
No one's ever looked more like a pirate.
[Prue] I'll taste the brush.
Lovely. Lemon and poppy.
Yeah.
-[Prue] Beautiful.
-I think the design's very clever.
And I think you've got
your flavours spot on too.
-[sighs in relief]
-[Prue] Well done.
I think that's beautiful.
And I love the painting.
Do you think it could be a bit softer?
I think it's okay, considering
what it's doing. It's not overly hard.
Structurally she's pretty sound as well.
Thank you so much.
[Prue sighs]
The saddle is beautiful,
the tail, the head.
Must have been heartbreaking
to see the thing collapse.
It was a little bit, yeah.
[Prue] Let's see what it tastes like.
It's a sugar biscuit
and that's, erm, honey buttercream.
-It's brave not to do gingerbread.
-Thank you.
I would never in a million years
have chosen that biscuit to build this.
-It's so delicate.
-[Prue] Mmm.
But you managed to--
I've made it three times before
and it stayed up.
[Paul] Just a shame
it looks the way it does.
It would've been right up there.
Would admit that's some of the best
biscuit things that we'd have ever had.
Thank you.
I'll get in the TARDIS
and we'll go back in time.
-Yeah, I've flown it before.
-[mouthing]
[Paul] For me, it's a bit basic.
I think, as a decoration,
it needs to be a lot more elaborate.
[Prue] But I think we need
to taste the gingerbread.
[Paul] I would've made that a little bit
thinner to allow a nice snap.
-Yes.
-It's a little bit thick and heavy.
I think if you were looking
at a traditional school report,
it'd say, "Needs to try harder."
-[Matt] Well done.
-[Noel] Well done, Maggie.
Looks a bit rough and ready.
The rough-and-ready look
of the painting was deliberate.
And there were two sails.
There was a tall sail at the back,
but the mast broke.
-'Cause of the water, the waves.
-[Matt laughing]
It's the way the cargo was loaded,
that was the problem.
-And that too, yeah.
-[Prue chuckling]
Don't give me that waffle.
Let's have a go at the biscuit.
Mmm, the cardamom
comes through well in that.
It's a lovely blend.
[Prue] It tastes delicious,
but it's a bit rough and ready.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-[Matt] Well done.
Well done.
I still feel in danger, because they both
said it was rough and ready, the finish.
Yes it was,
but it was finished nonetheless.
[Amanda] It's a mess.
Mine's the only one that's collapsed,
so I think the chances
of staying are slim.
[Maggie] I would give anything
to be here another week.
It's quite silly, really,
but when I've watched people
on Bake Off before, crying,
I've thought, "For goodness sake.
[chuckling] You know, it's only cake."
And suddenly it's all changed.
[chuckling] But everybody's
so much more skilful.
So, um, so we'll see, we'll see.
[Matt] It's decision time
for Prue and Paul.
Who will be named Star Baker
and whose time in the tent
will come to an end?
Week two, that was a pretty high
standard of Showstopper, wasn't it?
-That was great.
-[Prue] It really was.
I felt so sorry for Amanda.
If that rocking horse had held together,
it would've been right up there
because it tasted beautiful.
It was so delicate.
The one I'm most
worried about is Jairzeno.
You were looking at that going,
"It's kind of a ship."
Or a barge. He had a very leaky stern.
All his bakes have been rough and ready.
I think Jairzeno is in
a little bit of trouble, I agree.
And I would even put Maggie down there.
She struggled in the signature
and I wasn't convinced that that beach hut
was strong enough.
But I think, for me,
in line for Star Baker, Jürgen.
-[Prue] Yes, certainly.
-[Paul] Giuseppe's up there as well.
-[Prue] What about Chigs?
-I think Chigs has to be up there
because that snooker table is fantastic.
One of the names you didn't mention there
who did really well, I think, was George.
[Paul] George, I think,
sort of jumped up a bit.
[Prue] I love George
because I think he has real imagination,
and his concepts are always great.
-Yeah, they're really good.
-They're just sort ofâ¦
-[Noel] He's not very neat.
-â¦tatty at the edges.
I just had this thoughtâ¦
I mean, George grew up in Cyprus.
You were in Cyprus for a while.
You're probably, what, about 25 years
older than George?
You like the ladies. Do you feel
a sort of paternal sense towards him?
-Matt, this is going nowhere.
-Yeah. It's finished, don't worry.
Well, bakers, it falls to me to announce
who is the smartest cookie.
Do you see what I did there?
That was really good, wasn't it?
This week's Star Baker isâ¦
Jürgen.
[all applauding]
That means I've got the horrible job
of announcing who's going home.
This only gets harder
as we get to know you all,
but the person who's leaving us
this week isâ¦
Jairzeno.
Sorry, bro.
-You don't deserve to go, oh, God.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Loved the idea, mate.
I was half-expecting that result
because if you look at the Showstopper,
compared to everybody else's,
mine was quite basic.
-Oh, I'm so sad.
-[chuckles]
[sighs] I'm really relieved,
but I am absolutely gutted
that Jairzeno's gone.
We sit and talk all the time.
He's so lovely. He's so laid-back.
And his flavours are amazing.
I don't understand, wellâ¦
Someone has to go.
[Maggie] Amazing, I meanâ¦
But I think, this afternoon,
I learned the real meaning
of the little expression,
"The skin of your teeth."
[Prue] Well done, Giuseppe.
You really did good.
Thank you very much.
I've had a very, very good couple of days.
I'm very happy with how it went.
Jürgen deserved it entirely.
It's very stiff competition.
[Rochica] I'm so proud of you.
[line ringing]
I've got no plans
for stopping The Baking Terminator.
[Giuseppe laughs]
-Hello?
-Hi, Benjamin. This is Jürgen.
I'm Star Baker again.
-[Benjamin laughs] No way.
-Yes.
-[woman] Jürgen.
-[Jürgen] Yes.
-[woman] Is it true?
-It is true.
-[woman] My goodness.
-[chuckles]
-[woman laughs]
-Yeah, crazy, isn't it?
[closing theme playing]